Camaro and and wonder boys have their
run they've had their time I'm probably
gonna invest in the eating Gary's of the
world and we go no no no no no uh Wonder
Boy cool you're not fighting Kamal you
two older guys aren't fighting we need
to build up the the younger crop Ian
Gary's the next Guy Wonder Boy and Gary
that's the fight as a business now as
far as what I would love to see Camaro
and Wonder Boy fight I love both those
guys that'd be a phenomenal fight but if
I own the business I'm doing Ian Gary
and Wonder Boy I think Ian Garrett beats
uh Wonder Boy I think Aaron Gary beats
Camaro now it's time to put that rocket
ship on Ian Gary
off the names of these guys so Michael
Venom page was on freestyle Bender which
is adesanya's YouTube page he says can I
see myself there 100 regards to joining
the UFC there's so many fun fights for
him I got one yeah Ian Gary
there you go
dude right there that would be perfect
boom